Domain names are also essential
to several HTTP features,
including cookie security and SSL..
A single web server can handle requests
from multiple sites which it tells apart
by their domain names.
Apache calls this a virtual
host configuration.
NGiNX calls it having
multiple server blocks.
No matter what you call it,
it's why your HTTP requests
have a host header in them.
You have to tell that web server what
host name, really what domain name,
you're expecting to talk to.
As you saw earlier in the course,
the host header is a required
part of HTTP requests.
When a web app sets a cookie, it sets
that cookie for a particular domain
name, and further requests to that
demand will get that cookie sent back.
And SSL encryption certificates
are issued for particular domains.
SSL serves several different
security purposes.
By encrypting the traffic
between browser and
server, it prevents networks in
the middle from reading private data.
But it also let's the user's browser
verify that the site they're getting
data from is actually the site that they
expect, that when you go to google.com,
you're actually talking to Google, and
not to some bad guy who's
pretending to be Google.